her fellow colleagues they really really
loved her that's what we should remember
about him but she had a big heart Oh The
Good Morning America team is remembering
their longtime producer Thea
Trachtenberg who died on Easter Sunday
morning at age 51 she's a gifted
scripter a producing machine and while
producing those pieces oh the things she
has seen and you showed that in that
piece George just at that interview was
with mrs. Obama that was a first
interview with her as first lady and I
said I want Thea by my side Robin
Roberts Michael Strahan and George
Stephanopoulos spoke candidly about
their time with Thea Stephanopoulos were
called her work on interviews with
presidents prime ministers and actors
before revealing the interview she loved
most such an amazing human being such an
amazing Robin producer I worked with
Brooke with Thea on all of my big shoots
and you know she she did love that
bonnet won most of all she would come up
to me just about every week and say when
are we gonna do bono again when are we
gonna do bono again but not only was she
so much fun to work with but she it was
just an incredibly competent intelligent
and fearless producer she was a mentor
to so many on our staff Thea reportedly
battled serious heart and lung
conditions for some time she did not
have cope at 19 George Stephanopoulos
however revealed he has tested positive
for Kovan 19 I also learned over the
weekend that my tests came back positive
for kovat as well which is really no
surprise given the fact that I've been
here for a couple of weeks but I'm one
of those I guess cases that are
basically asymptomatic I've never had a
fever never had chills
never had a headache never had coffee
never had shortness of breath I'm
feeling great the diagnosis comes after
taking care of his wife ally Wentworth
who previously tested positive she's
going on her fifth day now with no fever
which is really a great sign slowly
getting out of bed a little bit more
each day so we're really happy about
that
just last week GMA mourn the loss of
cameraman Tony Greer who died due to
complications
from the coronavirus we loved every
single moment we were blessed to spend
and share with Tony our condolences to
his family in Chicago his mother Fanny
we've got to say this to you ma'am your
son was a good man he was kind he was
thoughtful he was always a gentleman and
George you know as a parent you can't
ask for much more than that